good morning uh welcome everyone uh to
day two of our Workshop uh yesterday was
absolutely fantastic and not only did I
learn a lot but I think we managed to
break many language barriers as it were
in trying to understand the concepts and
models that people across disciplines uh
use when thinking about the kinds of INF
and the sort of pitfalls in many of the
methodologies that we are using the
limitations uh across Fields so it is my
great pleasure today to um introduce uh
our dean of uh faculty of the faculty of
Arts and Sciences uh Professor Tamar
gendler who is an Exemplar of
interdisciplinary scholarship and whose
support I mean in her own work she has
uh worked across multiple Feats
philosophy psychology cognitive
neuroscience and um is very committed um
as uh you know an um administrator in
the University she has been really
heralding sort of intellectual Crossing
of boundaries and many
initiatives and programs to really
facilitate conversations as you all know
universities though we are all in um
with various um expertise is that often
speaks to very similar sets of problems
and challenges that we work on we don't
get to talk as much so with the support
of the Frankie program in science in the
humanities that Yale has very
enthusiastically uh not just supported
but encouraged faculty to attend and be
involved Tomar has um as I said in her
own scholarship and Beyond really been a
steward for uh cross disciplinary work
so it is my absolute Delight to invite
her to say a few words uh Tomar thank
you so much for coming thank you so
[Applause]
much thank you all and I'm sorry I
wasn't here to greet you yesterday
morning these are as you know
challenging times for universities I was
in New York helping some of our
colleagues and supporters
understand how hard we're trying but
though these are trying times for
universities this conference is an
example of what makes universities truly
distinct and what it is about the
imaginative Enterprise of creating an
Institutional structure that is
simultaneously engaged in the
preservation the creation and the tra
transmission of knowledge and in my mind
this conference epitomizes what is great
about
universities it is asking a deep and
intellectual question that is
simultaneously of theoretical and
practical significance it is distinct I
think to be able to have a series of
events that simultaneously engage some
of the deepest and most abstract
philosophical work really about the
nature of understanding in its most
fundamental sense and that
simultaneously brings in in very real
practical ways a set of empirical
disciplines it's rare to find a topic
that is not at the peripheral ref of one
field and the center of another but at
the center of every field of which it is
a part and it is rare to find a subject
that those centrally part of each field
and common enough to Merit joint
discussion is differentially illuminated
by different
methodologies so that's some theoretical
reasons to think this series of events
is doing what a university can do but I
also want to point out because I have a
second hat I'm not just responsible for
intellectual matters though I take great
joy in reading the academic work of my
colleagues
regularly the second thing I want to
emphasize is that this series of events
of which all of you you are a part took
advantage of structural features of the
University of structural features of the
ecosystem of which we are all a part and
to the extent that the group I am
addressing is a set of stewards of the
intellect at their own universities I
want to point out to you some of the
Practical features of this event this
project was carried out over years
it used multiple modalities it took
advantage of the fact that people can
drop in and out and nonetheless be part
of a Loosely knit social network for
each of the events that it carried out
it had it both in real time and
available for subsequent observation it
brought unexpected groups of people into
interaction with one another it took
advantage of the funding and environment
in which we find ourselves the Templeton
Foundation is deeply interested in
interdisciplinary issues in fundamental
questions it supplemented those
Resources with an entity on campus the
Frankie that had already established a
mailing list and a brand that allowed
these events to be legible and it
involved a wide range of Faculty on and
off campus pre did the very smart of
very early alerting this to me and so
when I went around and met with
supporters of the University this was
one of the things I talked about every
single thing that Priya did with regard
to this event is something that every
single one of you can do at your home
institution think about what are the
networks that have already given us a
pre-established list of individuals with
interest in a large range of questions
who are are the nodes at your University
that if you tell them about this they
will tell the world about this this is
not only in your
self-interest as Scholars the university
in the world is an entity that is at
risk it is being challenged for reasons
some appropriate some inappropriate but
the more we focus and celebrate core
Mission the more likely it is the
universities will remain the entities
that they have long been so that's where
I was yesterday I was in defend the
university space and I was writing this
on the train and so I wrote you a little
defend the university but I also want to
do a couple of specific Reflections on
the topic that this group has been
thinking about and then I'm going to
just close by reading a poem because
this doesn't have anybody from The
English Department department and so I
thought I'd give you a little bit of
literature at the end so on the front
page of the web page which I assume is
the cover page of the proposal that you
sent to Templeton it certainly feels
like the cover page of a proposal that
one would send to Templeton is the
incredibly resonant quote from Hume that
no amount of observation of white swans
can allow the inference that all swans
are white but the observation of a
single Black Swan is sufficient to
refute that conclusion and I don't get
to do a lot of philosophy I don't get to
do a lot of reflecting on texts so it
was a total pleasure just to live in
this quotation and its depth and I just
want to give voice to three thoughts
that occurred to me one I had not
realized till I started thinking about
this quote that one way to describe what
almost every academic does is to figure
out which features of the world that
seem shallow are actually deep and which
features of the world that seem deep are
actually
shallow that is for example the project
of our department of women's gender and
sexuality studies which aspects of the
world that seem Universal may be
particular which aspects of the world
that seem particular may actually have
deep foundations as I suspect we will
hear in our next talk but over and over
and over again including in the work
that we do in engineering which ways in
which this substance feels brittle have
to do with deep features of its
structure which are merely
manifestations of the idiosyncratic way
in which we find it so that's just
thought one Hume tells us
a way to think about the questions that
we ask is to think about where we are
mistaking surface for depth where we are
mistaking depth for surface ultimately a
platonic question about our capacity to
understand the nature of
reality two if Hume had lived in
Australia it wouldn't have occurred to
him that all swans were right white in
Australia lots of swans are black it is
contingent what it is that we take to be
ordinary and what it is that we take to
be
unusual that reminder is crucial for all
of our investigation that is not a
political statement it is an epistemic
fact about the world that all of us are
only partially exposed to elements of it
and on that basis we draw conclusions
note that as we fill build artificial
analoges to our own intelligence they
too don't live in Australia that is to
say they too are getting exposed only to
that which is electronically represented
and just like Hume who was very very
smart they might fail to recognize how
idiosyncratic the part of the world to
which they have been exposed is
third
Point how do we gather information about
the world one of the questions that this
assembly is thinking about is the entire
set of methodological worries that arise
to what extent do we seek information to
what extent does seeking information
distort the information that we're able
to get how do we become active
perceivers I spend a lot of time I
oversee all of the tenure and promotion
cases that come before us I see the
methodologies that ethnography brings us
which says sit back don't theorize and
you will see things more truly I see the
methodology that's brought
by areas of inquiry that say if you do
not have a theoretical framework you
will mistake what is important for what
is
unimportant both those things are true
and the methodological diversity of this
event seems to me to capture that in
profound ways all right those are three
thoughts on Hume let me close with a
wonderful poem by Mary Oliver this is
not a hard deep poem to understand this
is just a beautiful celebration of our
experience as humans on Earth
the
swan did you see it too drifting all
night on the Black River did you see it
in the morning rising into the Silvery
air an armful of white blossoms a
perfect commotion of silk and linen as
it leaned into the bondage of its wings
a snow bank a Bank Of Lies biting the
air with its black beak did you hear it
fluting and whistling a shrill dark
music like the rain pelting the trees
like a waterfall knifing down the black
Ledges and did you see it finally just
under the clouds a white cross streaming
across the sky its feet like black
leaves its wings like the stretching
light of the river and did you feel it
in your heart how it pertained to
everything and have you finally figured
out what beauty is
for and have you changed your
life thank you so much for inviting me
and for your
[Applause]
assembly thanks Tomar for that very very
lovely welcome and thanks to all the
attendees who are here so so we are
opening this morning's session with the
first talk Eduardo take it away thank
[Music]
you can you hear me there yes well good
morning everyone ER I want to stay on
time thank you Pria for inviting me I'll
have a few words to really share with
you all why is it that I'm here thanks
Tamar I'll have some comments about what
you were referring to before you have
the title there we're going to move move
from to look into some different type of
cation cation the way we examine it in
biological anthropology and I will say
more about that in a minute what I want
to do first is get a clicker to work
there you go I think it is important I
put together this slide which I don't
usually show to give you some background
on my own background right I'm not a
philosopher that much you've learned
from yesterday I'm not a computer
scientist I'm not a statistician I'm a
biologist by training but and with the
focus on Behavioral Sciences and that
has got me to move across disciplines
and I I really think that maybe it's
helped me to really appreciate and
embrace the opportunity that this
Workshop is bringing to all of us my
very first research paper was working in
a lab that studies the neurobiology of
learning and memory we were using some
short crafts that we were collecting
from the beaches in barosaurus bringing
them to the lab giving them electric
shocks to see if they could learn or not
they don't but then I went on to the PHD
to work with some experimental
psychologists so I went from
neurobiology to experimental psychology
working tackling some of the same
questions that I will be presenting to
you but in a control setting of a Lab at
the California primate center with my
mentors there so I'm going to come back
to this because it's I think it's one of
the things that I would like to share
broadly with my colleagues in biology
and anthropology and I was discussing
with one of you over breakfast I think
there's a lot to be said about the
benefit of taking the taking the leap
and cutting across disciplines as you
develop your own
trajectory the compass for the talk some
of you still remember what a compass is
some of you only know about GPS so what
I want to do is give you a little bit of
a few minutes of why I'm talking here
today then I'm going to make few
comments on causality in the biological
sciences a little bit of an introduction
to how we do that in biologic
anthropology with some very general
examples on questions and the type of
evidence we collect and then the core of
the 30 minute presentation will be on
some examples from my own research on
pair bonding monogamy and fatherhood I
really plan to be done in 30 minutes so
that we can have full 15 minutes of
questions and answers because I have
enjoyed those so much as well as our
times together over Breakfast tea and
lunch why am I here so sometime in I
think it was in 2018 I had my first H
teaching relief for and I went on leave
and I used that semester so that is five
years ago to really start pondering and
reflecting I want to know what I know
right sometimes you feel like I only
know that I don't know anything but I
wanted to know what I know and I did I
spent a lot of time on that semester I
put together a course on scientific
thinking and reasoning and one of the
books that I I went back to I knew this
book I don't know how many of you know
it it's from to British colleagues stop
working and start thinking and I think
that cartoon says so much of the
challenge we face on a daily basis we
can we can seldom find time to stop
Ponder reflect I mean just the pressures
to get money we don't even know what we
need the money for but we just need to
get more money and so in 2019 Dean
gendler launched a program that was
absolutely brilliant I think it
continues to run which was the teaching
relief for learning we were invited to
come up with an idea we needed to
convince them that we could make good
use of that time to take courses instead
of teaching courses go back to the
classroom and that was a time when I was
starting to to say listen we're not
reflecting on what we have learned in a
causal inference sense within my own
research I mean I have been doing my
research now for 25 years so I know that
some of the social sciences were
developing all kinds of me
methodological tools to get at causality
and so I literally enrolled in a
research methods course in Coal
inference talked taught in political
sciences and then I took an
undergraduate course one of the our
survey introductory courses in stats and
I did both and I completed my homework
and I I I passed and it was fantastic it
was fantastic because I realized that oh
my do we need to bring some of those
tools into biological anthropology I
contined working this there are all
kinds of developments that I'll be happy
to share with you because like like
Tamar said maybe some of these ideas
you'll bring to your institutions but it
was only a few months ago as I was
developing a new course on costal
inference that is I just went onto the Y
website and typed Cal inference and I
will admit here right now that I only
learned about the coal inference project
that we have at our own institution
maybe three four months ago and yes the
more you work the luckier you get I
emailed priia and I said I want to know
more about this and that got us talking
and I jumped on the wagon of what PR has
been doing and so that's why I'm here
only because I was seeking information I
was looking for ways in which I could
expand my my intellectual interest and
prepare myself better for doing my
research so that's my history of why I'm
here a little bit of the history I mean
biology has a long history of of
thinking and contributing to the
development of Statistics I mean this is
just two graphs from a wonderful book
that I most of you probably know the
book of Why by Jud Pearl is Sir Francis
Galton towards the end of the 19th
Century just developing a developing
ideas for explaining the inheritance of
height in humans I mean at the same time
developing the central limit theorem and
then so right this is a figure one from
a paper in pnas my understanding is that
historians of science consider this the
first path diagram he was trying to
understand what causes color code in the
guinea pigs that he was studying so late
19th century early 20th century move
forward and you go to an extremely
influential paper published by
evolutionary biologist erns Meyer at
Harvard in 1961 he published a paper
called causes and effects in biology and
what I want to draw from that paper to
are two concepts that I'm going to come
back as I discuss how we try to do
causal inference approximate causes and
ultimate causes just think of those as
in proximate causes we're trying to
understand why things happens in a
mechanistic way can be the cell can be
the organ can be the individual you can
think of physiology you can think of
energetics you can think of
Endocrinology ultimate causes ER Meyer
was developing this paper from what I
read in trying to bring some balance to
what was a very strong tendency to focus
on genetics from the 20s and 30s himself
being an organismic evolution biology
thought that we also needed to
understand causes at an Adaptive level
functional level and that's what it's
been referred ever since as ultimate
causes well going to come back as we as
I examine what progress have we made in
understanding proximate and ultimate
causes for the phenomenon that are of my
interest at that time this is the top
panel of a figure of a paper that I'll
show next you can see that the
understanding there was that causality
was rather unidirectional it was bottom
up you just go from The genome in a very
programmed way to the the cell the
organism and the environment and
whatever that happens in that generation
one that's pretty much inherited to
generation two and that was said and of
course this has changed over the years
and now for for many many for a long
time we've develop subdisciplines like
evoo where we understand that causality
we need to understand causality at
different levels yes there is an
influence of the genome in what comes
next but so there is influences of what
happens at the level of the cell of the
organism and the environment and it is
not unidirectional but it is reciprocal
and some of these changes that occur
during ontogeny during your lifetime
maybe also influencing the following
generation so we have moved away most of
us I would like to think from what all
of you are familiar which which was so
influential as well and with positive
and negative consequences as portrayed
in the selfish Gene book that Richard
Dawkins Road it's almost 50 years ago so
that is what we call these days the
extended evolutionary
synthesis how do we do this within
biological anthropology in a nutshell
biological anthropology which we also
call Evolution anthropology physical
anthropology we are trying to understand
what it is what it means to be human if
we take biology and evolution into
account so a when you study humans of
course we have come to realize Embrace
include the component of culture you
cannot understand what it means to be
humans if you consider culture but
something that is it's a rather
challenge these days to communicate in
classroom is that I am of the firm
opinion that everything begins with
Biology because at the end of the day we
are made of cells we're made of of of
genes Etc but you cannot ignore culture
either so these are some questions that
we ask both on a very deep time scale
and also a very broad spatial scale what
makes us different from other living
organisms for example chimps when did we
really start cooperating for producing
or obtaining the food as the as the
drawing on the top right shows you and
once we got that food when do we start
making fire were we using the fire to
warm ourselves were we using the fire to
cook and now that we cook suddenly our
complete
nutritional ER functions change when did
we start walking on two legs these are
some typical classical questions that we
ask in human biology in biological
anthropology and then we go on to get
data and we never get all the data we
would like to get this is by the way I
was thinking there's there's something I
keep telling students all the time and I
think that you you'll appreciate and
agree with this there is this we we
forget that we are never getting the
data we would like to get right we get
what we can not what we would like to
and the students don't understand it and
and I sometimes I feel like we forget
that when we're reading papers or
reviewing grants the kind of evidence we
can get fossils that is I would say
that's a rather unequivocal we we can
hold a skull right we can hold a stone
tool but we can quibble about who made
it carrying and storing we can look at
material culture genetics there is
information on genetics that can help us
reconstruct the path past behavior and
that's my focus the catchphrase for
behavior is behavior doesn't fossilize
and who one of you showed yesterday I
apologize think it was Thomas the first
slide was some footprints on a beach and
then we looked at a track of a fox well
what do we make of that what do you make
of that if now you find a footprint that
you know has been dated to 1.3 million
years ago in the savanas of Africa you
can make of that a
lot
how have we used these these approaches
and what are the kinds of questions that
are closer to what I've been doing for
this time one of the things that so many
of us wonder is in in what makes us
humans what makes us love right what are
the proximate and ultimate causes that
have developed a living organism that
can connect emotionally with another
living organism in a very PE way that we
don't see in many taxa right we refer to
that establishing some peir bonds what
is it that makes some living primes
develop this kind of emotional bond in a
very peculiar way with their off with
young I'm not going to call them their
offing for a while we'll see we'll come
back to that and some other living
organisms don't do it paternal care more
specifically we're narrowing down to the
full side of my research why are some
primates PE living and socially
monogamous where are some males such
excellent fathers those are really the
two Central questions that I want to use
to share some findings but probably even
more than that share some concerns some
limitations really embracing the
uncertainity that there is in all that
I've
done much of the research that I'm
synthesizing in merely 17 minutes has
done in collaboration with hundreds of
students assistants and some colleagues
these I wanted to mention Anthony De
Fury we were students together at UC
Davis when we were grad students 10
years ago Marcelo rotundo you didn't
pick up that you're not paying attention
Marcelo rotuno has been the field
manager in Argentina working with me for
30 years Maggie Corley and Alba are two
Junior colleagues who have joined the
project now for some time and again to
going back to when said listen we need
to do something so it was 1819 2018 2019
that we started working on the
paper that we published in the yearbook
physic anthropology summarizing the
research we've done with some of these
prates in fact it took us five years no
it was published in 2020 we started
working on this on
2013 there was a science paper published
by one of my colleagues one of my the
most famous social Evolution biologist
team claton BR at Cambridge making some
claims about the evolution of
monogamy and let's say we we did not
agree with many of the conclusions and
we just do not have it in us to produce
the quick turnaround to refute some of
the claims it took us seven years it's
the kind of work that it's it's it's
thoro it's deep doesn't make it into
science you cannot summarize it in a
tweet but we published a 60-page paper
that we're very proud of because we
really got into the details of the
issues we had with the inferences made
for the evolution of social monogamy
mammals our Labs our Labs we have labs
in the forests of Ecuador Peru and
Argentina and we've been working there
for anywhere between a few years and 28
years in Argentina and I work also in
labs in the states where some of my
colleagues Al in Bastrop Texas and Davis
California are responsible for captive
colonies of some of these peer living
taxa I'm beginning to look back to my
background the importance of tackling
the same questions from different
different experimental approaches and
the power the power of moving back and
forth between what what a lab can offer
you and what the natural setting of The
Field can offer you and drawing the best
from
each I will not be talking about this
but we're going to have 15 minutes if
any of you so those of you traveling
from Europe who are trying still trying
to figure out how to deal with jetlag
we've done a lot of research on the
evolution of diality and nocturnality
because the owl monkeys that I stud in
Argentina are not nocturnal were not
working during the night I did that when
I was young not doing it again it
doesn't pay off and other reasons but
just bring this up to the questions if
you want to learn more about that tons
of students assistants I want to thank
them we do that a lot please let your
own students reach out we always have
opportunities to bring young scholars to
the field H to do research with with us
and we have some wonderful facilities we
have a field station in the city of
Formosa we can host a researchers
collaborators in and we have camp now
we're going to Argentina the lab in
Argentina and the bottom right image is
showing you roughly 200 hectares 500
Acres which is really our main backyard
that you can see in yellow the system of
trails one of you was asking me what do
you do well we produce the data that
feeds into those documentaries that
hopefully some of you have watched I
enjoy B BBC Netflix life on the planet
David atenor we're producing the data
that goes into that that's the kind of
setting that's the kind of lab where we
are going I want to go more deep because
I I was thinking about it when was the
last time you took a course on on evolu
biology or that that you heard about
Evolution biology methods my impression
is that for most of you it's been a
while so I I felt it would be
interesting to hear I mean I was this
learning from you what happens day in
day out so I want to share a little bit
of that what happens day in day out is
that you go out in the forest you wake
up early you drink Matti and you really
have to go find the subjects from which
you're going to be collecting data and
how you do that it's a challenge in
itself more and more we are relying on
some of the chips and devices that some
of you have been telling us how you
produce and this case what we're doing
is we're capturing all monkeys with a
rifle with CO2 darts sounds easy it's an
extremely complicated proced and we're
fitting them with Telemetry colors to
track them in the forest or we're also
fitting them with accelerometers that
that your iPad tracker ER we don't know
how many steps they they need to take to
stay fit but we can collect a lot of
data that summarizes their activities so
we do that and that allows us to find
them and when you find them it depends
on what you're doing it depends on the
day it depends on on on the samples
you're collecting you may be collecting
just direct observations it's funny how
we've been talking about observations
right I mean my goodness could we spend
a week discussing what we mean by that
some of us are calling a footprint an
observation of War it's only of a
footprint since since the fox wasn't
there nor the human was there right so
sometimes we are literally collecting
data from what the animal is
doing sometimes we're collecting monkey
poop from the ground sometimes we're
just going through the forest collecting
what we call life history data get a
sense of what's happening in each of
those
families we've been doing that year
round and this is I mean I need to go
tell our Dean that it doesn't stop we
need to keep doing it year round need to
we need to be in the field the monkeys
don't stop the soap opera continues and
we've been doing that nonstop since May
1996 when we do the maths and and it's
not big data by any means of this
Workshop but it comes down to imagine
that for 28 years you've had somebody in
the forest four five hours a day every
single day of 25 years that is that
captures the effort that has come in
terms of genetics in terms of ultimate
causes I mean can we start looking at
what happens over an extended period of
time we're looking now at the fourth
generation of identifying individuals
these are not fruit flies but they are
not chimps so we there's a lot of power
in starting a system where you can be
looking at great grandchildren in 20
years something you cannot do with
whales or elephants we collect genetic
data and one of the reasons we capture
them is because we can produce high
quality genetic material for some of
these animals of known sex known date of
birth we have cell lines established as
part of of the collection that I
developed for the San Diego Zoo
sometimes we collect tissue and other
times we just collect feces again
methods what what does it mean we we're
are going to come come back to that I
mean what does it mean when I estimate
some mediator of a potential causal path
from something I measure in poop in
blood in an individual cell we collect
Behavior life history demography data
and of course we have a very
comprehensive panel of variables to say
something about the
environment why are some primates PE
living and socially monogamous by
socially monogamous I'm just saying that
they spend time together right without
going into the details of what may or
may not happen in our modern
societies people live as a pair in one
apartment God knows what happens when
they're not there but we call them
socially monogamous we're going to
tackle that first
question and I want to go slowly on this
one so so want to capture your attention
again please on purpose I'm keeping the
text we're going to read slowly because
it's Central to
understanding the challenge of the
inferences we're trying to make let me
just say to give you a little bit of a
time scale is that these all monkeys if
we were to connect them on a
philogenetic treat to humans we probably
need to go back 40 million years ago if
I remember that well so we're making
we're taking a big leap in the inference
this is from a paper it was a note
actually this is this is one of these
editorials on the article that I was
referring to before by one of my
colleagues evolution of Maman Society
the hypothesis is the narrative model
that we want to explore says that the
distribution and abundance of food top
left panel Illustrated with some fruits
or maybe the Predators the middle photo
or maybe the pathogens the bottom yeah
those potential factors it's unfortunate
that it says here
determine they are associated with
whether females of a given Maman species
are solitary or gregarious Now we move
to the right a female may be socially
solitary or gregarious in relationship
to food to predators to the risk of
transmission
disease the hypothesis is that male
social strategies are determined in a
second step by infanticide risk how much
a female is concerned there's a risk
that some male may come and kill her
infant options for Parental care
engaging males in the care of a young
intrasexual selection by that we mean
that it's within the same sex males
fighting between them for access to
those females all of that is going to
determine the spatial temporal
distribution of receptive females so we
move to the right panel and depending on
these conditions we're expecting we're
predicting that we're going to see a
social Arrangement along pairs one male
and one female we may see solitary
females with some males roving over the
ranges of them or we may see one male
holding control to several females we
may see several females and several
males together that's the idea this
drawing in a number of forms has
profoundly influenced all research done
in primatology and to a large extent in
biological
anthropology of course we can we can
make it a little bit more nuanced and
you can also draw this and how on Earth
do you go into our forest and try to
produce data that will give you a sense
of satisfaction these days I worry about
that more than whether it's going to get
published or not that you have really
made progress and you you have no choice
at least I don't know or any of any
other option but to choose a section of
that that and I just want to illustrate
what we've done for the top right corner
of the graph we said okay let's examine
let's collect some data Define some
variables that relate to the
distribution of males and females in
space to see how much they move how they
move how that may contribute to
understanding the ability of a male to
monopolize access to a
female right the ability of males and
females to meet with other partners
really you really imagine yourself I
mean this is what I tell the students
you need to decide me can you can you
have two
girlfriends well maybe one is in New
Haven the one is in MILF can you have
two boyfriends well maybe now with zoom
if you decide that you're maintain those
relationships virtually but you cannot
have girlfriend or boyfriend 10 of them
in 10 different countries all over the
world and that's a little bit the
exercise we're doing so our monkeys one
of the three taxs that we study
everywhere you look at always you find
them pay living what we call socially
monogamous and pair bonded meaning that
we infer that there is this preference
and that's thinking about humans that
happens all over the world humans are
developing a primarily relationship with
one single other individual it's changed
can be the same sex different sex same
gener but there's always a preference
for one over the others all monkeys
always per living always per Bor
it this is the forest I was showing you
before you go into our forest and you
have 18 of these groups and they're
really distributed in space like I'm
showing you there remember that's
roughly 200 hectares 500
Acres let's take two of those backyards
right think of them as backyards they're
roughly five hectares that's maybe 12
acres so these guys are holding a
backyard of five acres one male one
female there's another group group that
has their neighbors and another five
hectars the problem is that we also look
around and in these neighborhoods some
of them got to really have twice as much
area but they still have only one male
and one female
so what we ask ourselves is why is it
that if some of these males have the
ability the approximate causes the
mechanisms to really range over 10
hectar why don't we see some Evolution
that produces a mail that now is going
to range over the
ranges of these two smaller territories
in red why don't we get a drive for the
evolution of a polyus male if the guy
can cover 10 hectars if he can monitor
10 hectar why don't just monitor two
territories of five instead of one of 10
the answer is we have no clue why not so
that's really after 28 years there is no
I mean it's very very difficult to
resolve this what we're trying to do now
is get into much more detail in
measuring the distribution of resources
which is extremely
challenging why I mean some of these
males actually all of these males are
wonderful fathers why are some males
excellent fathers and that's a
fascinating question in evolution of
biology let me tell you why you can
connect with these guys being wonderful
fathers Right male penguin keeps an eye
on the chicks mom goes fishing and
finding food seahorses you probably know
that the males hold the
pregnancy but mammals are very very
different for one thing fertilization is
inside the female tract and that
generates father and certainty and
second mom as opposed to the Penguin and
the seahorse mom is stuck with
investment with the demand for
energetics between pregnancy and
lactation so it is a puzzle in alian
reproductive biology why males would
commit to a single female in a socially
monogamous
relationship one possibility we do know
that our monkeys provide an awful lot of
care I mean if you have children if you
have grandchildren encourage them to
browse the web to look at videos of all
monkeys taking care of the babies is
fascinating a couple days after the
baby's born the father is primarily
involved in taking care of the young
except for nursing the male does it
everything
and we do feel Based on data from the
lab as well that the infant has a
stronger attachment to the father than
the mother that's remarkable for a for a
for a
mammal they carry the infant they share
food with the infant more than the
mother the groom they touch they play
they're the primary caregivers of course
leaving aside nursing which is not which
is not
trivial we wanted to understand what are
some possible proximate causes of the
involvement of the father with the kid
of the young how that may be feeding
into explaining peir bonding and
monogamy and again on purpose I just
pasted the whole text of this article
because it illustrates a little bit what
I'm trying to to get traction on in my
own discipline notice the paper is from
2021 and for for three years a whole NSF
Grand went on to collecting monkey Shed
from the ground hoping that so but this
is the path where trying to connect so
what is the hypothesis the hypothesis is
that for a male to engage with a female
one possibility is that the male is
helping the female reduce the energetic
burden if I help you take care of a
young then you can rest then you can
sleep so we want to look at
endocrinology we want to understand if
cortisol which forget about don't think
about cortisol anymore as a stress
hormone that's all that's throw it away
it's much more than that and we're
thinking thinking of it as a metabolic
gatekeeper levels of cortisol are
related to how we're metabolizing
glucose right but that matters in the
brain I mean we need to if we if I could
get the data watered I would like to
know what's happening with cortisol and
cortisol receptors in the brain I cannot
do that well can you do blood no I can
do that can you do urine no I can do
that what can you do well I can collect
monkey monkey poop from the ground and
hope that as a monkey excreted or
whatever it excreted something the poop
gives me an adequate proxy of cortisol
in the brain we did that this is an
unusual note and section for our journal
and our discipline but we just wanted to
do it and we more and more we're doing
multimodel selection model averaging but
we can play with numbers all you want
what we cannot allow ourselves to forget
is what is the quality the internal
validity the robusticity of the
variables that we have and more and more
with my colleague and and wife Valia
we're feeling like is it worth to put
all this effort in trying to infer
something about the energetics of
Parental care from a measure like the
one we can
get ultimate Cession what are the
benefits of paternal care huge survival
of infants we think that may be part of
the explanation of what we're saying
this you do not get this these rates of
survival in any other primate for a for
a wild animal they are doing one
carefully and maybe it's associated with
having both parents provide
care the other ultimate question is okay
if if this is adaptive if we can imagine
this is going to evolve over time the
same way I was talking about why don't
we see a polygynous male strategy evolve
how come did we get to have a male care
strategy to evolve for that we need to
understand if there's father or son
and if the males who are keeping an eye
on the females are really the ones who
are sing the young it's crucial that we
go from describing their pattern as
sexual monogamy social monogamy they're
hanging together sexual monogamy they
are copulated with each other genetic
monogamy they're really only producing
young with each other and we know now
that the system we have it's quite
extreme because we have no other primate
for which we have the kind of data we do
we have now tested 120 diets of Purity
fathers on Offspring and not a single
time we have assigned the paternity to
another male that it is not the pur
father most of you are familiar with the
fact that when we assess paternity we're
not confirming the identity of the
father we're simply just deciding which
ones are not assigned paternity so that
may be another answer partial answer to
the evolution of this that a male who is
committing to a monogamous relationship
now succeeds in sing offspring that in
turn probably have that tendency to
provide care as well and stay peer
living and peer bonded so the idea is
that maybe you really have peer bonding
as
necessary but we don't know if
sufficient condition to then facilitate
the evolution of fatherhood and paternal
care
you can read about all this I added this
because the the talk is going to be
public so you can see the Y today for a
whole piece on this and a book that we
just edited only this year it's it's
bringing together 30 years of research
on our monkeys all over Latin America
and you can really find there some good
synthesis of the research that I have
presented this is the last slide with a
list I mean really this is a shopping
list of the things that I would like our
discipline to consider some more it is
primarily observational we normally have
very few
subjects this is not for my discipline
but I I noticed yesterday we didn't
really talk and I I invite comments on
this we didn't really get in our
conversations and presentations on what
what differences are we going to make
when we're talking about prediction for
the individual and prediction for the
population I think we have a lot to
discuss there because the the public
they're not getting it they're confused
our we talking about we can model we can
predict but not telling them this is not
going to help
you sometimes we have no clue about what
are important effect sizes that we want
to find or report a document we we
literally have no clue I don't know what
is the difference in cortisol as
estimated from poop that really means
something to the
animal there's no discussion in my
discipline about the difference between
noise and bias actually I think it's not
happening in any field right now
everything is a bias well those are two
different Concepts I recommend that book
that Daniel kaham just published it's
quite interesting to to get the basics
of of the distinction between those two
who was it yesterday Samantha made me
think oh my goodness missing data do we
have work to do there so there are
things we cannot do but all of these we
can let's do them if you're missing data
think about them let me know why you
didn't get those data I mean what are
the causes of missing data that's huge
we're not doing it enough I think
for the students they confuse data and
inference from data all the
time and then all of this we summarized
in a commentary to a journal of our main
society that we need to keep working
this is Central to the workshop on the
difference between statistical inference
and caal
inference thanks to all the agencies and
I thought that would be a nice collage
to
finish
[Applause]
thanks so much Eduardo for opening eyes
to very long causal chains that are
needed in inference in your discipline
so we're open for questions
Julia
yako that was fascinating so I learned
that barbar maak are also excellent
fathers but the reason there is like um
these groups are like live together and
because paternity is uncertain the males
look after all the children just in case
they're dares and actually males form
bonds in Barber Max over like the
looking after the young so I mean the
result is the same that they're very
good Fathers but actually the
relationship um they have with the
females and the males have with each
other are very different so I was
wondering you know like even in
different types of
creatures um with maybe similar type of
habitat um similar type of resources and
so on
like you know like you get to the same
outcome from very different uh for the
very different reasons and how can you
untangle all these things and how does
more broadly is it clear what determines
whether a group lives together and
there's like either like a bigger group
lives together as a patriarchy or
matriarchy or like this like just um
like pairs basically like in this case
so
thanks I'm reminding myself that this is
going to be recorded and made public but
I'm not going to say anything that I
haven't already published in writing so
the B ma there's one single Paper
empirical paper from the 70s was a very
relatively short paper on barbar Ma that
again and again SKS drawn into the same
pool of all studies without
distinguishing the how robust the
information is I my understand is that
bar some colleagues of mine have studed
to work on them again but the outcomes
are the same but the extent to which the
questions have been examined I don't
think they are so going to the but what
matters what you said is I think it's
interesting that it is true that it's
difficult to measure we have tons of
papers discussing how we're going to
Define paternal care right I mean think
think about your own families what does
it mean that a of yours is taking care
of you more and more we're learning with
with studies across Societies or human
societies that there could be a lot of
observational learning that the young do
from the father but if we're looking at
the father I mean if we didn't know that
the the son is there we will not be
describing this adult male as teaching
anything but the the the child is
learning from the father just through
observation so we make in a very
simplistic way we talk about Direct Care
and indirect care the varar Maks like
every single other primate I know except
for the titty monkeys do not have in any
way or manner the kind of direct
involvement with the young transporting
them caring I mean the the the the baby
yells and that goes to its rescue now it
is possible absolutely possible but much
harder to document that the m presence
of adult males are providing some extent
of care because those males may be a
barrier to potential Predators those
males may be a a barrier to potential
males who may kill those infants so how
we assess then then you brought up the
word bond which I did as well and and
that's a rabbit hole because again how
are we going to Define Bond we do not
have I I use the word for our research
in the in the while but if you as me I
mean I will say here on record that I
don't know if we have any solid data to
speak about a bond for the all monkeys
in Argentina this is another way in
which in biological anthropology we can
make our emphasis more robust we can
draw we can use the process of of
abduction we need to do comparative
biology because the way in which I can
do it is okay I don't know if a male and
female are monkey I don't know if the
male and the infant have a bond in the
same
that if I cut that relationship there's
going to be distress I haven't shown
that I haven't shown that they will seek
each other but because they're always
together I cannot separate them right
but I'm start looking around and I see
there are all kinds of studies spaning
decades on all kinds of other systems
where when they see what I see they have
also shown that there is a substrate
that there approximate mechanisms
there's a physiology there's an
Endocrinology that speaks of a bond
we don't have that for barban Maks
technically speaking we don't have it
for Al monkeys the closest we get is to
some research on krets and Tity monkeys
in captivity where that is some
wonderful work documenting the bonds so
how you get to that barbar Maks live in
groups where you have several males and
several females and again we do not have
evidence that the relationship between
males and females in those groups is
similar to the relationship you have in
peer living taxa
but how we we really make progress in
understanding how we got there it's it's
profoundly difficult I I I I do have
hopes in terms of the genetics but the
genetics then also seeing how the
genetics unfold right we can we need to
make so much more progress in the Black
Box between genes or genomes and this
very very complex
phenotype thank you um it's uh wonderful
topic and I was wondering if you could
say a little bit more about the
statistical Norm that was just mentioned
in the paper that you wrote and whether
there have been discussions and people
have been questioning this statistic
statistic Norm so in the paper in the uh
one one more back is the sorry the one
there's a footnote in your third to last
slide yeah the P
value oh yeah this one yeah can you say
a little bit more about that yes
absolutely don't get me started oh maybe
maybe you shouldn't
say i' love to i' love to I have two
minutes already in the 9s I was trained
by psychologist they knew about meta
analysis there wasn't anything new about
it right they knew about meta analysis
but but already back when I was a gr
student I realized that our hypothesis
significance testing was profoundly
inadequate for everything I was doing
and still I still had tables Full of
Stars it it looks like a cosmology
experiment e so so now in 2021 again
through this period we decided that we
wanted to share with our colleagues but
this was because I was following with my
colleagues at the American statistical
Association and the statement that the
American statistical Association
published in 2016 saying misuse and use
of P values they needed to include the
use in the title but the bottom line is
99% of people are misusing P values and
statistical significance followed by the
nature paper with a 100 signatures
saying let's stop doing this and I'm
begging you stop doing it because
because I think it's made so much damage
for most research situations definitely
I'm speaking for ours in biological
anthropology there are seldom any
opportunities where you're going to make
progress definitely not in caal
inference by deciding whether this is
worth reporting or not based on an
arbitrary dichotomus cut of that it's
the same no matter what you're studying
so again I'll go on record what was the
reaction that it was the first time in
my life that the two reviewers said this
has to be published and the editor
decided to send it to a third and the
third said this has to be published and
the editor eventually I guess she
published it ER but but why why don't we
see traction I think it's because we
need to train our younger colleagues to
take responsibility you are the expert
we need to go back to domain knowledge I
think it was some again the the easiest
is no I don't know what this means but
the P point or4 it ought to be important
that's what we're getting from students
a lot and they're not thinking I go back
to my second my my second slide you have
to know your discipline you have to
think hard you have to think deep you
have to be open and modest with what you
hope you can accomplish and all that
it's is absolutely counter to
structuring your findings and
Publications around an arbitrary for me
it's mind-blowing that we're still using
05 and and we haven't so that's there
was a lot but I I I'm optimistic I'm
optimistic we're making
progress quick questions oh one quick
question
yeah okay sorry so I just I just I have
one so one the question is what
inferences do you have uh about how your
monkeys choose the needs or to put it
differently what's the nature of
love the the nature of love the nature
of love very quick answer right the
nature of love I suggest let's talk
about it later but but the INF how they
choose how they choose that's where you
need the LA that's where you can you can
really have we have a lot of expertise
in how we can assess preference be of
mates be of food anything you choose so
we can do that in the lab we haven't yet
ER because the challenge is even if we
do it with a very carefully crafted
study design we still have relatively
low number of subjects and so and I
suspect that the answers are going to be
all over the place it'll have to be done
in the lab and and and that's as much as
I can say with the time we have I'd love
to let's sit down nature of we can all
contribute the same about the nature of
love I mean I'm no expert there thank
[Applause]
you